free information and the communication
on internet is forbidden in China so
you're facing so-called a great firewall
to block all the major international
internet service and the Machine China
you have 100,000 of internet police just
sitting there till it or block whatever
the informations is sick is not we
cannot appreciate about so but still you
know the the Chinese tweeter you know
and transpa a still all offers certain
kind of freedom on this nation never had
before
so and also daily when the events
happening you know people start to make
common side which Buda a very strong
platform for civil
opinions and discussions which already
completely changes the landscape of the
political situation I think those those
technology platform constantly put the
carbon on trial and the ivory events
every policy they make will be people
the love about it under the order make
fun about it you know this is amazing
for younger generation I think internet
technology can be more freedom in
everywhere especially in China State
like China or other assert or in society
to maintain this kind of control is to
censor and to block the freedom of
expression that's once that is not
possible then then to maintain this kind
control it's impossible so obviously
internet is the answer to to achieve
civil society or our to kind of young
people to be engaged to be involved and
to be informed and to freely associate
and communicating with other people this
is
truly miracle gift from the human
struggle I think it is is so beautiful
and I think it's beyond the imagination